i don't think it's possible to transcend
memetic desire or to get rid of it
completely we'll be rid of memetic
desire when we're dead and it can be a
tremendously powerful thing
right it can spur us on to imitate great
models um so i think
we have a lot of agency but we you know
freedom is something that we can win or
lose
i've got a quote that i need you to
explain to me okay
okay we want what other people want
because other people want it
and it's penciled in eyebrows all the
way down down
to the depths of the nth circle of hell
where we all die
immediately of a brazilian butt lift
over and over again
what's that about that is a quote from
dana tortorici who's the editor of n
plus one magazine
here in the states uh she's talking
about memetic desire she wrote a
beautiful piece about
instagram and the effect that instagram
is having on what we want
and her finding was basically the topic
of my book that
the nature of desire is mimetic meaning
we always look to other people we look
to models
who help us understand what to want and
that the social media platforms like
instagram
are essentially just these machines of
generating
desires memetic desires everybody's
imitating the desires of everybody else
and you know the joke is it's like
turtles all the way down it's like
memetic desire all the way down like
where where does this end it
makes this miserable and depressed
because we don't realize that that's
part of what
social media is doing to us it's just
providing billions of desires out there
and we can't tell you know the signal
through the noise
why do we have memetic desire then is it
adaptive
memetic desire is according to rene
gerard who
sort of discovered this phenomenon in
the late 50s and early 60s
is just a part of human nature it's part
of what it means to be human
uh perhaps uh if we got back to the
evolutionary process perhaps it's
something that
humans developed in order to sort of
separate ourselves you know from from
the great apes so
this may have actually been adapted from
an evolutionary perspective
to help us create culture uh to learn
language i mean imitation plays a
fundamental role in all kinds of very
positive
human things social interactions
if if we're not imitating each other the
right way it can get a little awkward
so you know this gerard said that
imitation actually helps prevent
violence and helps cultures to form
so it's part of the human condition
something that we can't
escape but very few people are kind of
aware
that there is such a thing as memetic
desire and we we have this
modern hyper individualistic hyper
rationalistic
understanding or view of ourselves and
why we want the things that we want
where you know i lay eyes on something
and i want it
because of x y and z and i describe all
of these objective qualities
without taking into account that i'm a
social creature and i'm
constantly looking to other people
that shape the perception of value for
for things for people
for groups this affects everything from
politics to you know to the stock market
do we have any wants that aren't mimetic
do you think
or are there humans out there who don't
have any wants that aren't mimetic
that's a great question and a topic of
um of great debate
uh among people that that read gerard
some would say no i think
there's some nuance right there's some
there's some distinctions that we can
make
for instance instinctual things that we
have a biological
drive for uh food and water
um sexual pleasure these kinds of things
are see
they're kind of like built into us we
could call those desires
but i like to sort of think of those
more on the needs spectrum
uh but there are also seem to be some
basic fundamental human desires like
classical philosophy has identified
these
like the desire for knowledge uh the
desire for
survival these are just basic things
that every
that seem common to all to all humans um
unless something kind of you know
goes wrong but in terms of the more
abstract desires
as we get into things that are sort of
less grounded in any kind of
instinctual basis and we start talking
about careers
and lifestyles and fashions
there's nobody that desires those things
without having some kind of a model i
mean they don't
generate those desires ex nihilo like
out of thin air
because they're they're already embedded
we're born embedded into this social
process
uh and you know we we don't we haven't
created these things ourselves
so even even today i mean the irony is
that things that used to be
probably not so much in the realm of
desire like drinking water for instance
uh you know there was just water now
now there's like 20 different brands of
bottled water with all kinds of
different
minerality breakdowns and and marketing
aspects
most people like haven't actually
analyzed those things so
they they look to other people and they
they shape
their the valuation of those things
through mimesis
so most people think that they're the
conscious agents of their own
wants and desires and then if
determinism
hasn't put them in the ground mimetic
desire can come and
hammer the nail into the coffin and
throw a bunch of concrete on top of it
is that kind of
how it's looking at the moment exactly i
think that's probably a good way to put
it yeah usually the less
the less memetic we think we are the
more we probably are
fantastic obviously there's an
implication for maslow's hierarchy of
needs there that you kind of have
this bottom level of needs but then
above
needs is desires and then you say that a
lot of these desires are kind of
interchangeable so the hierarchy becomes
very messy as soon as you get past the
needs
yeah in fact i mean as soon as you get
past the very bottom level of the
hierarchy
i would say that there's no hierarchy at
all in the
in the universe of desire if you will
there is no hierarchy
so you know maslow's pyramid if you can
picture it sort of
uh goes up and our needs become a little
more focused
and smaller the higher we get towards
the top and
i think we could probably lop off
maslow's hierarchy
right above the first couple of levels
right the physiological needs the needs
for security like having a roof over our
head
as we move beyond that i think we just
cut the pyramid right off
and we enter this very messy world of
desires
that doesn't have a strict hierarchy
because there's there's often not a lot
of
objectivity to it we look around at this
universe of
people around us and the reason there's
no hierarchy is that we adopt
desires or we derive desires based on
people that we come into contact with
more than any kind of like
uh like teleology that's guiding us
towards this very one specific thing
and i'm not arguing that that doesn't
exist um if you're religious
you you could i think you have a strong
case to make that there is
uh there is some ultimate desire you
know dante talks about that at the end
of the inferno
but for most of us um as as memetic
creatures we spend most of our lives
kind of bouncing like like pinballs in a
pinball machine you know from
from different models and from different
desires to the next and that's one of
the reasons it's important to be able to
see
our mimetic nature and to be able to
sort of put some
to lay over some structure because you
know from some objective
evaluate to step back from the mimetic
game and to be able to understand like
what what is it that is there are
certain things that i should want
um that are sort of objective goods that
may be lost in
kind of the memetic craziness and noise
of the modern world
someone said that mimetic desire is to
psychology
what gravity is to physics is that right
yeah yeah so if that's the case how was
it discovered
so um it was discovered by a french
academic named rene gerard
who came to the state shortly after
world war ii and
his degree was in history and he
discovered discovered memetic desire
um outside of his field of expertise
through reading classic literature
because he believed that literature
um even mythological literature classic
fiction held deep anthropological truths
inside of it so the analogy here would
be to
um heinrich schleioman who
was a gentleman in 1871 who set out to
find the lost city of troy
with a shovel under his arm and a copy
of the iliad
under the other arm he had a shovel and
he had the iliad in 1871
and all the archaeologists everybody
laughed this guy
kind of just like out of the room but
two years later he found
troy because he believed that the text
actually held clues like there was there
was some truth he took the text
seriously
and he scrutinized the text and it
allowed him to discover the city
when nobody else took it seriously so in
other words his method was wrong
according to the experts but the guy
used the iliad and he found troy
so he's the idiot yeah all he did was
read a book
all he did was read a book that
everybody else had read but they just
dismissed it
as as not important to this quest to
define the city
gerard is like that in that he read
classic literature
and mythology and he he believed that
the text held
very important secrets about human
nature
and he wasn't a literary critic he
didn't even study literature
he was self-taught but he scrutinized
the text that way
and i think it probably helped that he
had fresh eyes you know like sometimes
we see
things easier when we're outside of the
domain
where people are like in the weeds and
we kind of stand back and have fresh
perspective and we can see things that
other people miss
and that's what he did with the
literature and his discovery was
that desire is memetic in a lot of the
great classic
novels um at least of the western canon
like dostoevsky cervantes
a lot of great french literature um
like proust and he noticed that all of
the characters in these novels none of
them want spontaneously like their
desires don't arise
out of the blue there's always some
model for them somebody influencing what
they want
and gerard was one of these great
interdisciplinary minds
there's not a lot of them left like he
studied anthropology history
literature so he he saw this discovery
in literature the way that schliemann
did in the iliad
this truth and then he began to look for
it in other places
uh and he found it everywhere and it's
now you know
60 years later after gerard started
talking about
mimesis and memetic desire we have
neuroscientists
finding mirror neurons and realizing
that you know in fact
imitation is like hardwired into into
what it means to be human
and if we imitate things like language
and facial expressions and fashion
why wouldn't we also imitate desires
that's exactly what i thought as soon as
i learned about
rene gerard's work like why would we
believe
that our children copy the faces that we
pull at them when they're a toddler held
in our lap
but at some point what you get agency
someone gives you the agency card at age
16 or something like right okay
imprinting is over mimetic desire
doesn't begin
no of course the imprinting that you
have the it makes sense in an adaptive
characteristic as well right you
you watch someone do a thing that looks
successful
as a hunter-gatherer that expedites your
progress and your learning because you
don't even need to be told it
you can just watch them do it and then
maybe you can be told it as well that
adds some flavor to it too
like it's just turbocharging learning so
why wouldn't that happen
but as you start to roll into higher
levels of abstraction and you have these
sort of loftier goals and
especially when you are exposed to far
more stimulus
stimuli than you would have done usually
but
it can be hijacked in a a pretty sort of
crazy way
yeah and you know the smarter that
people are the easier they can
convince themselves of anything
including that you know
memetic desire is not a part of them you
know so the funny interesting thing is
that in children we see memetic desire
easily
you put a bunch of toddlers loose in a
room and one of them picks up
a single toy that none of the other
other
kids were concerned about all of a
sudden a second and a third one comes
over
and you know the the more of them start
oogling the single toy
the more attractive it becomes like this
power of attraction
it's kind of like when you're walking
down the sidewalk and you see a bunch of
people like huddled around a corner
like watching some breakdancers or
something like that it's just yeah it's
like moth to a flame
you know and that's memetic desire you
know we're taking our cues from other
people so
in children it happens and it's kind of
funny like one
one kid wants a single toy and the other
one immediately just starts crying if he
can't have it too
and we you know we know from childhood
development this happens there's been
many studies that i reference in the
book but the funny thing and children
are open about their imitation and open
about who their models are you know we
call them role models
and they're not really embarrassed of
their imitation they imitate their older
siblings and they're proud to do so
you know in fact the the better they can
imitate the older brother or something
like that just
you know the better it may want to go
tell everybody you know how much how
well they're doing at being like like
the older brother whoever
as we get older though it seems that
the the mimetic part of ourselves we
kind of like
bury it you know it's it's sort of like
it's not
good to be known as an imitator as an
adult especially with
you know the way that entrepreneurship
has sort of gone in the last 20 years
like
we really prize innovation and imitation
has become a dirty word
so it seems like the the memetic part of
what it means to be human has just went
underground it doesn't mean that it's
disappeared
we haven't like engineered it away if
anything we're probably more memetic
than ever because of social media
but as adults it's not something that we
talk about very often
well we call it out right people break
the fourth wall with regards to the role
models that they follow think about the
conor mcgregor walk
you know that walk as he goes into the
ring or the type of shirt that he was
wearing he wore that
outrageous versace shirt to the races
one day
and then next summer every fast fashion
brand for men
has these sort of floral like what would
have been typically classed as like [ __ ]
shirts
but now the coolest thing on the market
because conor mcgregor wore it
everyone's fine with that
people seem to be like yeah yeah but
that's conscious i know i'm doing that
i'm doing the walk it's kind of
um self mocking almost and i'm breaking
the fourth wall about
i know i'm doing that and for some
reason we presume that we're the
conscious agents of our own desires
it's not brazilian butt lifts all the
way down it's like brazilian butt lifts
when i choose to get it but not when i
don't
yeah exactly breaking the fourth wall is
a great term to describe this because
you know things do happen where we break
the fourth wall
the fourth wall is strongest uh with the
people that are close
closest to us and that fourth wall
doesn't get broken a whole lot
so it's it's one thing to imitate conor
mcgregor
for for me to imitate conor mcgregor and
his crazy shirts and the way that he
walks and stuff like that
um because he's conor mcgregor it's
another thing
for me to have that relationship of
imitation
with somebody that is like my colleague
or somebody in my workplace somebody
very close to me
or my own business partner and gerard
says there are two different kinds of of
models of desire
for the most part there are those that
are external mediators of desire because
they're outside of our world
and they don't really imitate back
there's no kind of
there's no there's no threat of of this
kind of reflexive
weird relational situation that can turn
into rivalry and create conflict
and then there are what he calls
internal mediators of desire and those
are people
inside of our world we're not just
talking about physical distance here
we're talking about
our social world like existentially
speaking these are the people that if
we're imitating them they might notice
that we're imitating them conor mcgregor
has no [ __ ] idea that i you know i
wear his shirts right so
these are these are trickier and i think
we break the fourth wall on the external
ones and we can joke about it
but rarely does that happen with with
the internal mediators of desire
no the only reason that you would ever
do that would be if you were taking the
piss
right exactly you've got some the new
australian in the
office or the brit in the office and all
of the americans decide that they're
going to try and do the british or
australian accent which all of you are
terrible at
and and um yeah that's
that's the way it works so is nemesis a
kind of alchemy because it seems like
you can create a desire or a demand for
something
which was originally worth nothing by
just having
other people appear to want it yeah you
know
rory sutherland who i've spoken to wrote
a great book
uh certainly say that it's it's alchemy
uh and i i tell a story about eddie
bernays who basically
used alchemy to manufacture uh an
outcome
in in the early 20th century in the
states
women didn't smoke in public it was
totally taboo but all the men were
addicted to cigarettes because
they were included in the ration packs
in the first world war so all the men
smoked
none of the women smoked in public very
rarely did they and bernays was hired by
one of the large
tobacco companies american tobacco that
made lucky strikes
and lucky strikes realized that if they
could tap into the
the market for for female smokers
especially in public then they'd make
you know the modern-day equivalent to
billions of dollars back then and
bernays
who was the nephew of sigmund freud by
the way so he he understood
psychology and even though he wouldn't
have used the term memetic desire
he certainly understood that the
principle
of mimesis and that humans need models
of desire
and what did he do he engineered this
elaborate stunt
at the 1929 easter day parade
he had women attractive women come out
of the churches with
packs of lucky strikes planted inside
their their fancy overcoats
and on cue they whipped out the lucky
strikes
and started smoking them just defiantly
walking down fifth avenue in new york
city
and these women served as models they
were all of the
newspapers were were photographing them
and bernays said look at these women
smoking torches of freedom
they're they're they're defying this
taboo they're
finally free because they're able to
smoke and it's it appeared that they
were they spontaneously chose to do this
but in fact the whole thing was
engineered by bernays
because he realized that this this model
of a bunch of women
at the same time spontaneously deciding
that they were going
to defy this this taboo was incredibly
powerful for all of the other women that
saw this
i mean it's this is like memetic desire
101 and then there's the element of
rivalry in there
um you know with with the men and and he
used this
to create some kind of alchemy to
generate
a certain outcome so we do have to be
careful um you know marketers know this
very well
um and you know even people that are
sort of like really
really slick in the dating game uh know
this very
very well too right um there's sort of
no
no better no better way to
to generate desire for oneself
and to be able to walk into a bar and
have your you know an
attractive friend of the opposite sex
just pretend to be totally fascinated
with you or something like that
right there always needs to be a model
it seems like
signaling and mimetic desire uh very
closely interlinked is there a
relationship between this
i think that i think is a deep
relationship and it's very simple it's
just that
models of desire signal to us what is
what is wantable
so it acts as a as a source of
legitimacy for our own desires
think about it if if i want something um
that nobody else wants or you know if i
want to
go on vacation to a certain spot or or
or you know pursue some path in life
um most people if they if they
express this desire and they can't find
anybody else around them
who also seems to think that that
thing's desirable they begin to doubt
themselves and wonder if they're
if they want the right thing this
happens in romance it happens in careers
now i don't think i mean there's
certainly some people and i think
entrepreneurs are the
prime example like everybody could tell
them they're crazy and that they
shouldn't do something
but they do it anyway that's a little
bit different though that's that's not
that's not necessarily a a desire that's
just people
weighing in like well i don't think this
will work for x y and z reason
when it comes to like actual desires we
look for other people the models to
signal
the legitimacy of that desire for us so
i think there's a very deep connection
there has to be equivalence of like a
first mover
right as you said with the kids you've
got the kids in the play play area
and let's say that they're all doing
nothing then one does something
now that something can have been
iterated on a mimetic desire
that they saw yesterday or that they saw
two weeks ago or that they
watched mum do in the car on the way
here or something but there does have to
be a first mover so there has to be
um gradations of how mimetic
certain desires are that we have there
are certain people who step further
outside of the overton window of what is
normal acceptable behavior with regards
to their desires
and there are others that are slap bang
in the middle of the normal distribution
yes i think thinking of it as a
gradation or as a spectrum of mimesis
is exactly the right way to think about
it so let's take the little girl in the
room who picks up a bright red fire
truck
she may pick up that fire truck because
her dad is a firefighter
and and you know that and that's the
reason why she was the first mover
so it's nothing to do with the other
kids in the room it has to do with some
external factor
or something you know she saw on tv the
day before
but uh it could have nothing to do with
that it could just be
because the color red is just this like
bright red color and all of the other
toys are adult have dull colors and
there's some
kind of instinctual response where the
red was attractive i mean we know this
in animals
with birds and flowers so so perhaps
there there is an instinctual basis for
people moving towards things
and and desiring it and then the mimesis
uh maybe follows that
so i think there's all kinds of reasons
why somebody could be a first mover
um different gradations and the trick is
kind of like getting to the source right
getting to the bottom of it
so if everyone's converging on desires
this must
cause conflict because more people are
more alike
which means that increased rivalry and a
greater desire for differentiation as
well has to come out of it
yes the the next step so the memetic
desire is like step one of gerard's
theory step two is that memetic desire
quite naturally has to lead to
conflict because we're imitating the
desire of a model
where we're now pursuing what the model
is pursuing
so we've we've de facto made ourselves
in
into some form of arrival so the model
is now
an obstacle to us in in the pursuit of
whatever the thing is
so you think of a like a hyper memetic
environment like
um university the students come into the
university
maybe with all kinds of like grandiose
ideas of
what they want to do when they graduate
if you pull them
on their first day let's say it's you
know it's a class of
a thousand students you might get eight
or nine hundred different answers of
of different things that they want to do
post graduation
but the funny thing is by the time that
they
graduate if you ask them on the last day
you might get
a hundred likes in in some sense like
the the their their desires of what they
want to do
just kind of converge through this
memetic process
like one of them is like oh this is the
this is the company to work for
this is the industry to work in and
their desires converge and then it
becomes hyper competitive and they're
competing over
the same types of jobs competing to get
into the same companies and it creates
uh creates conflict um that's a
relatively superficial
example but it this can manifest itself
in all different kinds of ways and we
so basically the counter-intuitive idea
here
for gerard is that our conflict does not
arise primarily
from our differences it actually arises
from our from our sameness
it arises from mimesis from imitating
each other which draws us closer
together
and sort of brings us into a situation
of
of imitating one another but kind of
wanting to hide it
um this weird sort of situation of
of of needing to differentiate ourselves
while we're all
secretly imitating ourselves and the
best example of this for me is social
media
social media it has a homogenizing
nature to it if you think about the way
that twitter or linkedin or facebook
we all have the same profiles we all
it's all kind of structured
the same way we have the same wiring and
we have to present ourselves
in that way we have the same number of
characters to make a point
so it actually has brought us closer
together nobody really knows who
who the models are to follow i mean they
change all the time and there's this um
you see there's like this great anxiety
to sort of differentiate oneself
while in an environment where
everybody's imitating everybody else in
some way and
responding to everybody else so that's
this is the great paradox i think
of of memetic desire yeah it's
interesting especially on social media
because you have people that get to the
top
right so they have a power law um
advantage because more people
proportionally far more people see their
content
and then they look at it and they think
oh well he's luke's got good reach with
that tweet
so i'll add that into the library of
potential mimesis strategies
and then luke's done it again he's done
it again with that same sort of tweet
and you see this right you see this with
different structures whether it's
putting clapping clap emojis in between
each word or
whether it's using a particular hashtag
like what is a hashtag
it's other people saying this is a trend
this is something else that i agree with
and a lot of what people are trying to
do there is achieve success
through the adoption of that trend
here's something that's worked well
that's a signal of high value high
status intellect
humor whatever therefore i'm going to
adopt it i'm going to absorb it into
myself
yeah you see it all the time on social
media like when one person
develops a certain tactic all of a
sudden you start seeing it everywhere
it's imitated everywhere
um you know and maybe the origin of that
was some
you know program of how to get more
engagement in 30 days or something like
that right so
people start doing all kinds of funny
things like asking these questions and
um you know i can you can almost just
sniff it out right as soon as you see it
but imitating there's a lot of cargo
cult stuff
happening um not only on social media
but in uh
you know in the startup world for
instance and it's like imitating sort of
the
the external things like will magically
bring about
some some kind of result so you see
entrepreneurs like imitating all kinds
of like surface level things
like ways of dressing ways of working
kind of lifestyles like different the
ways
even that we communicate in our email
exchanges like there was this like
hyper-mimetic trend while
i was living in california where like
all of a sudden it seemed like overnight
like nobody wanted to use capital
letters in emails anymore and it was
like it's not cool it means that you're
like you're not busy enough if you have
to capitalize the first word of your
sentences
and use punctuation and it's like in the
course of a year man i'm not kidding
like
like that just happened so there's like
this imitation of like all these like
funny external things
that have very very little to bear on on
the success of the company
around the valuation right and and the
value creation
so you know what we're imitating is is
very important is it is it like the
superficial external things like are we
doing that with some like
auto magical expectation that if i put
these three emojis
after all of my tweets suddenly you know
i will
you know have the following that uh elon
musk has
no it doesn't work like that if i wear
the black turtleneck then i get all of
the insights from creativity and
marketing that steve jobs had this is
what we saw with
elizabeth holmes right from theranos a
woman who was a
complete shyster and a total total con
artist was very successfully so
um and she wore a turtleneck the same
way that
steve jobs did there's actually clips on
youtube if you look hard enough of her
real voice
changing her voice yeah so she lowered
her voice to imitate the men that were
in the industry
because she thought that having a lower
voice would signal that she was
more masculine more disagreeable more
conscientious more industrious harder
working
um but the product that they created
the what was it called the winston or
something what was the thing that they
made
oh i forget the name of the action
anyway some famous
uh scientists from the 1900s they named
it named this thing
edison that was it um and uh but that
was [ __ ]
total [ __ ] didn't do what it was
supposed to do at all but she'd got
all the surface area stuff she'd got all
of the easy to achieve things
here's another thing man that i think
about a lot scott alexander put this on
his blog a little while ago
talking about how um fashions work
two rungs apart in terms of class or
group hierarchy
so if you're upper class kim kardashian
let's say
you can wear heels with a pair of popper
sided
jogger track suit bottoms to an awards
ceremony
and people are going to think oh yeah
that's so cool it's like the clothes of
the underclass
it's the clothes of sort of the street
chav but
worn by someone who's really really
classy but if you're only one rung above
them if you're perhaps lower middle
class you can't get away with that
because you're so close that you could
be confused
the signal that you're giving off and
the mimesis isn't a signal
of i'm so cool that i can wear something
that's two rungs below me
or i am so rich uh even though i might
be in a sort of lower middle class or an
underclass position
that i can wear what the people above me
are i just look this way and i'm above
my station basically
um so you need to have these gaps so the
way that people model stuff and who they
choose
is also a signal in itself right okay
what is this going to adopt
within me what am i trying to say with
this is there any confusion that this
might actually be me
slipping down a peg as opposed to moving
up a peg
it's brilliant and that has everything
to do with what we talked about earlier
that kim kardashian can do that because
she lives in a different world so it's
not confusing
she's going far enough away into
it's an external world for her right
with external mediators of desire and
internal mediators
so she's going far enough away so it's
not confusing
where if she sort of stayed in the world
of celebrity and did something
um it could create a lot of conflict so
that that has to do with the distinction
of like what world do the models occupy
and we see that in in all kinds of
different domains the interesting thing
with elizabeth holmes though i have to
add is that
what she did like we can say that it's
silly we can joke about the black
turtlenecks but
to some extent it worked in in the sense
that she created an
aura around her alchemy that alchemy is
total alchemy
that that got people presumably very
smart people i mean it's embarrassing if
you watch the documentary
the amount of people right that are on
there touting her
um so in a sense memetic desire
models like literally distort reality
you know we we project all kinds of
things onto models
um like metaphysical things that they
don't even possess
um so there's a kind of a game that's
being played it's like who can make
themselves out to be
the right kind of a model um and if you
can do that you can
raise you know i forget some ridiculous
amount of money that elizabeth holmes
was able to raise
and then it's a self-fulfilling prophecy
like the more money you're able to raise
the more people that you get like you
know former heads of state
the more people don't even question they
just they they now have models of desire
to follow
and it makes the seventh and eighth and
the ninth one extremely easy
what goes on when mimesis happens to
social groups then
usually when mimesis makes its way
through a social group
through kind of memetic contagion
it leads to the group becoming more
homogeneous if there's no kind of
external reference in the social group
uh gerard found that you know and this
can happen at the micro level it can
happen in a family
it can happen in a company it can even
happen in a community or in a country
um where everybody is reacting
memetically to
everybody else and it kind of creates
this what he calls
excuse me a memetic crisis and gerard
found that
uh at the root of a lot of societal
crises
is like out of control memetic desire
where
there's no sort of clear models to
follow there's no
shared models and everybody's kind of
looking to everybody else and
reacting to everybody it's interesting
we don't you know in in
at least i'm thinking of you know 2021
america there's not a lot of shared
models right i mean what part of the
problem is there's not a lot of like
like models that we can agree on in
terms of like who we should be following
so it just it crea in in the absence of
that there's this kind of memetic crisis
where different
sort of groups and factions form and
everybody is reacting to everybody else
and gerard found that historically these
kinds of memetic crises are
solved through uh what he calls the
scapegoat mechanism through
um turning away from one another through
the imitation of one another
and sort of taking out the tension
taking out the aggression
on on some on some scapegoat that
basically provides
some temporary relief from from the
from the internal mediation that created
the crisis
you dig into that a little bit more so
why does that happen how is it a release
valve
it it happens because the when people
are imitating one another in conflict
and an aggression
um the they they think of it this way
think of a bunch of people sort of um
standing looking at one another sort of
um
fighting taking their cues from the
other side tit for tat aggression
and somebody or someone comes on the
scene
uh a third party that allows them to now
stand shoulder to shoulder
and which in a sense like releases them
or makes them forget about their their
aggression towards one another
and they are able to essentially unite
against whoever the scapegoat is so it
actually it causes group cohesion
um when there's a scapegoat um so i mean
this goes all the way back to ancient
israel where there was a sacred right
for this right every year at yom kippur
the high priest would symbolically
transfer
all of the sins of the people onto a
goat
and then they would collectively drive
that goat out into the wilderness into
into the hands of a demon to die and the
the act of
transferring all of the all of the blame
the transfers of blame
onto that scapegoat and then very
importantly the
act of collectively um driving that goat
away exiling that goat created
cohesion among the people whereas before
it was kind of
a as hobbs would say like a war of all
against all
uh tons of interpersonal conflicts the
scapegoat is like concentrating all
conflict and all blame onto a single
kind of fixed point it'd be like you
know if you have cancer running all
throughout our body
imagine how nice it would be if we could
concentrate uh all of the cancer into
one cell and eliminate the cell
well the scapegoat mechanism is
essentially doing that
but for a social process not a
biological process
so i imagine in an individualistic
society
this is even worse right because you're
so siloed out
everybody is their meritocratic
utilitarian objective metric of success
that they can add to society
and this must make the scapegoat
mechanism even more so you've got the
collapse of grand narratives all the
things that used to cohese us together
in the past
attending church going to the same
sports games together
the paradox of choice is that when you
can follow whatever interests you have
you're less likely to cohese with the
people around you about their interests
as well
yeah that's exactly right and i think
when i look at
like the united states today the one
thing that seems to bind groups together
more than anything else like the most
identifiable and easiest thing
to identify the group is who their enemy
is in other words like
who their scapegoat is so gerard had a
funny saying one time he was like
you know political partisanship is
essentially um
you know having the same scapegoat as as
everybody else or something to that
effect but
aside from politics it's just it the
scapegoat mechanism
creates group cohesion through
this uh this kind of transference of
blame it binds people together
through that so i think that i think
you're right i think that as our society
becomes more
uh hyper individualistic and fractured
we will see
more and more need for the scapegoat
mechanism because we have
less of the shared values like one way
to think of shared values would be like
shared models
right that's why i said it's hard to
find like like
models that everybody agrees on i once
tweeted out i was like
who's a who's like a model that like all
americans can like
like hold up as a good example and i
only got one response and it was dolly
parton
the rock the rock everybody loves the
rock that's who i devoted for
i think i think the rock is probably up
there yeah yeah but they're hard to find
i mean the fact that we're talking about
the rock
[Laughter]
shows you and not and not some like
ideals or virtues
or like a sense of like what it should
mean to be
like that just says everything that you
need to know about the state that we're
in
there's a study that my buddy rob
henderson told me about
in 2008 which is when
obama got elected the first time both
parties
loved their own party or like their own
party more than they disliked the other
party
2012 when they were polled people
disliked the other party more than they
liked the one that they were voting for
so it literally is like a protest vote
it's a vote against what i don't want
to happen as opposed to what i want to
happen which is crazy when you think
about it like that
does um you had a story of how
lamborghini came to fame
in the book you tell us that yeah this
is a beautiful story of
a mimetic desire that turned into
memetic rivalry
that ended well uh which is rare and and
it's why i thought it was important to
tell the story because
memetic desire can lead to great
innovation and it can be a tremendously
positive motivating force
for people as long as you don't let it
metastasize and become
negative and destructive and
self-destructive so
the story of um ferrari and lamborghini
is fascinating so enzo ferrari of course
built the
the ferrari automobile company known for
these great racing cars and ferruccio
lamborghini who's the founder of what we
today know as the as the lamborghini
automobile company started out making
tractors in the middle of the 20th
century he made these beautiful tractors
and he did very well for himself as a
businessman and
to the point where he could buy himself
a few ferraris
so you have this successful entrepreneur
ferruccio lamborghini driving these
ferraris
and in in one of his top-of-the-line
ferraris the clutch
just kept on breaking on him and he
couldn't figure out what was going on he
would take it to the ferrari shop they
would charge him an arm and a leg
send him back and the thing would break
three months later just infuriated
he finally had his tractor engineers
open up the hood
take a look at the clutch and he found
out it was the same damn clutch that
he used in some of his cheaper tractors
now this really pissed him off because
when he went to ferrari of course
you know they charged him 10 times more
than the cost of the part
so lamborghini said screw this
i'm just going to take a really top of
the line clutch and
and put it in my car so he rigged his
car he made himself a better ferrari by
putting one of his
really sturdy clutches in and his his
argument was like they're not using
a clutch that can handle the power of
this vehicle
so he did it and then he souped up the
engine while he was at it
and then he he would go out on the auto
strata near where the ferrari factory is
where
the ferrari engineers would test their
cars and lamborghini had souped up his
ferrari to where it would beat the new
ferraris coming out of the garage
and they're like what did this guy do
finally lamborghini said i gotta go tell
enzo ferrari
you know what i think about him and his
cars so he finally gets a meeting with
the great ferrari
and he tells them listen i think your
clutches are [ __ ]
and enzo says well maybe you don't know
how to drive a ferrari and you should
just stick to making tractors
so if lamborghini leaves that meeting
and and basically resolves from that day
that he's going to make a car
and he's going to make a better car uh
to to prove to ferrari that that he's a
better engineer he was an engineer by by
trade
and within two years he had um he went
on a whirlwind tour of the
of the world he went to japan he went to
detroit
he looked at the great automobile
manufacturers and he imitated
the crap out of them and it's funny he
he says in his
uh in his book he goes i have no shame
he goes i learned from the best i
imitated the best i didn't innovate much
at all
i just took the best the best parts from
all of these cars
the manufacturing from detroit like the
the the beauty of the beautiful design
from
i just put them all together and within
two years he made a lamborghini model
that
in many respects was superior to the
ferrari in i think 1966
um and he and you know they've been
making cars ever since
so you know that the whole company was
born in essence out of memetic desire
the thought of making a car didn't
hadn't even dawned on
on lamborghini uh until he had the right
the right model and the right rival for
it um
he didn't just wake up one day and
decide to go into the car business right
it
arose through this this mimetic uh
rivalry that he had
and the ending of the story is um he
realized after
after a decade or so of fierce
competition with ferrari
uh there was debate whether lamborghini
should enter into racing
um and at the time they they weren't
they didn't race they just made
beautiful touring cars
that had trunks different than a ferrari
which was primarily a racing car
um i'm getting into formula one by the
way these days so i
because i wrote that story it's it's
solid it's giving me
one more thing to bet on um anyways
uh he he eventually realized that the
rivalry would not end well
if he continued that way he wanted to
spend more time
with his family he knew that if he
entered the racing business
he would just be in a war with ferrari
until the end of his life so he said
we're not going to enter the racing
business
he handed over control of the company to
other people he retired to a beautiful
winery uh which is still in italy to
this day you can go buy lamborghini wine
and visit farrucha lamborghini's estate
where there's a beautiful
bed and breakfast you can get a tour of
a barn where he's got all his classic
cars
and he lived a very very happy and
fulfilling
you know end of his life um and it you
know it was it was an example of him
recognizing um listen my rivalry
produced this beautiful company and car
but if i
if i don't stop um it will basically
lead to my
my death and and he was a really big
into bull fighting and he sort of
likened himself to the bull in a bull
fight
he said i'm like a bull and i i know
what happens to the bull
um if if it if it doesn't realize that
there's always one more thing
there's always one more thing that i
could do so i'm going to resist the
temptation to kind of take this to the
end
and i'm going to kind of opt out of the
game while while while i'm ahead
basically and that's what he did and the
badge on a lambo
is a bull right it's a bowl that's where
it comes from
it comes from his lifelong fascination
with uh with with bull
fighting and there's probably a little
hemingway involved in that story i'm
sure
that's so sick man so i'm fascinated
with people's ability to step into their
own programming
so so far we've laid out a fairly bleak
picture of human nature we're just kind
of these
npc very easily
uh imprintable creatures what about
stepping into
our own programming like is it even
desirable
for us to get rid of our memetic desires
surely there has to be some wisdom in
crowds right the evolution of memes
is and um ideas would suggest that the
ones that stick about are at least
partly useful
yeah i think we um i don't think it's
possible to transcend
uh memetic desire or to get rid of it
completely um
you know we'll we'll be rid of memetic
desire when we're dead
um you know as as while we're living
we'll always have it
and it can be a tremendously powerful
thing right it can spur us on to
to imitate great models so i think we
have a lot of agency
we have a great deal of agency um but we
you know freedom is something that we
can win or lose
um you know it's what happens with with
you know vices and addictions you know
we literally lose
freedom or we can develop freedom so i
think we can develop
um freedom to to be more intentional
about
uh our lives and the kinds of models
that we choose the kinds of desires that
we pursue
but we can't do that if we're not even
aware that this is going on like if we
can't step into our own programming we
have to know what the program is
and part of why i wrote this book is
just to let people say
here's here's part of the programming
you know part of a fundamental way that
that humans are wired
is to be memetic we're constantly
looking for models of desire
and just being aware of that it allows
us to step back
gain some self-possession take stock of
your life
um of the decisions that you're making
and then step into it
in a more intentional way but i find
that
very very few people even acknowledge
that this is a
hidden force uh in the world you know a
hidden force that is to psychology what
what
what gravity is to physics you got to
know that it exists or you can't develop
the right muscles to combat it it'd be
like going through life
not knowing that that gravity exists you
know and you never work out and you
wonder why you have like your back hurts
so memetic desire is is similar um
we can step into it we can i think
stepping back
uh taking stock and then stepping back
in is kind of
the approach that i recommend in the
book well thankfully the audience that
listens to this show are
terrifyingly reasonable and unbelievably
sensible they're happy to
to swallow whatever sort of
uncomfortable truths they need to so
let's say that
someone's listening and they want to
become this intentional agent right they
want to become a sovereign individual
what are some of the tactics that they
can use to notice when they've been
memetically hijacked yeah i think
you know as you become aware of it you
can actually name some of your models
positive and negative
i think anytime you're able to name
something uh just kind of like emotions
you gain some control over them so you
know when i can when i can name
um the people that i'm emulating and the
people that i look to
as as as rivals i gain some control over
them so i mean it's an exercise i would
do i'd actually like take stock take a
piece of paper
and take stock of what your world of
models looks like
in different domains who's your model
for investing
who's your model for fitness uh who's
your model for
like what you know your relationships
want to look like you're familiar with
some good good identifiers of this
someone says i want to find out who my
model for fashion is or for
fitness or whatever what are some of the
things that the questions that they can
ask themselves to help identify that
you can um i mean when it comes to
negative models you can always ask
yourself
like who who makes you uncomfortable um
when when you see them during doing
certain things or having certain
successes
um that might be the kind of negative
model or rival i think the most powerful
way to do this though is to actually
look at your past and
the formation of of your goals and your
desires
so i had a good friend of mine say i
don't know if you've seen this movie
called a few good men
it came out in the late 80s jack
nicholson he watched this movie
20 years later and when he watched it he
realized that for the last 20 years of
his life
he had been basically saying things that
came from the movie
and like modeling certain mannerisms and
certain ways of dealing
with people based out of some of the
characters from that movie and it wasn't
until he saw it 20 years later he was
like damn
that movie was literally like my model
for certain kinds of
like goals that had been his genesis
that had trickled through
other people and then come back to him
and then come back to him yeah
[ __ ] so so doing almost like a like a
history of desire
in our lives starting with our parents
and and family and friends and
that's that's an important exercise to
do and i i guarantee
you if you take the time to do that you
will begin to identify some models that
you probably forgot that you had
um that's one that's one really real
really easy way to to get started but
it's not
it's not an easy exercise because it
takes time you might start with just
with college
and then and then ask yourself like you
know you might realize like hey i'm in
this career that i'm in today because of
some models that i had while i was in
college
and i you know at the time i never kind
of critically tested
them i didn't kick the tires i just like
took them for granted and now here i am
and
you know i'm not really that happy and
maybe it's because you know i've never
really taken the time to understand how
they influenced me
so that's that's one that's an easy
tactic naming the current ones is
another one
um you know i recommend in the book the
importance of uh
of of a retreat every year if you have
the time to do it and the reason that's
so important is because
it's hard it's hard to see something
that you're in
that you're literally in especially
something that's inside of you
so you have to extract you know without
without some form of like pulling back
or extracting ourselves
we know we don't have the perspective
that we need so you know this is like a
bill gates think week
but but for desires um i try to take a
few days every year
um i mean it's the most important thing
that i do every year
um you know i i recommend that to gain
the perspective just to sit
to sit in silence like things will
bubble up i talk about that a lot in the
book actually because it's you know it's
it's the genesis of this whole project
for me
um if i hadn't had the luxury of taking
that time i never would have realized
some of these things
that's i i find at the end of the year
i make more growth around my end of year
review in my new year planning process
than at any other time and it's so dumb
so today i've actually done my half
year check-in i was like right i'm gonna
sit down i'm gonna dedicate half an
afternoon to it
and just go through everything and you
get so much more clarity because you
actually think
look at all of the things that when i
was less encumbered
by culture and habits and routines and
fears and desires and all this sort of
stuff
look at the things that as close to my
truth i was able to get on a piece of
paper
and then yeah look at what the [ __ ] i'm
doing with my time now
and look at how far how the huge delta
chasm that's between these two
and i go right okay yeah yeah right okay
let's brush away all of this stuff let's
get rid of all of that [ __ ]
let's get back to the things that really
matter the highest points of
contribution
no doubt you know i i like it there's a
quote by james clear that i like a lot
that i i
kind of transfer to the book and it's
you know we don't rise to the level of
our goals we fall to the level of our
systems
and part of why it's so important to do
this is to see the systems that we're
part of that we might not even know that
we're part of like
what is this what is the system of
desire that i'm like swimming in right
now um where you know what riptide might
i be in
um we never sort of see that while we're
in the moment it's only in those moments
of of stepping back and gaining
perspective because
we all have systems right there's
probably one for podcasters there's i'm
sure there's definitely one for authors
i'll
be the first to tell you that having
just written a book there's a system of
desire there's certain things that i'm
supposed to want
there's certain lists i'm supposed to be
on certain like thing
and you know i need to create a distance
from that and say well
is the goal to be uh a new york times
bestseller or
is there a better goal than that maybe
like a long term 12 15 20 year goal
um and and it's important to gain that
perspective or else we just take the
we basically other people give our goals
to us if we don't do that
yeah i'm hearing a lot of goodheart's
law throughout this
when the measure becomes the outcome
you end up having some very sort of
strange externalities so for instance
you could sell a book
which did a million copies but let's say
that it made the world a
totally awful place or let's say that it
was
really xenophobic or something and
absolutely annihilated your career and
people were hate buying it so they could
burn it in the street
and you were causing riots to occur like
you have achieved the goal
but because you've looked at the measure
as the actual outcome that you're after
and i suppose that
in the modern era as well again collapse
of grand narratives lack of
reach back to tradition and stuff like
that people don't really know
what it is that they're supposed to want
we look to other people and just over
time you get this weird sort of
fisherian
runaway increasing caricaturism of
bigger lips bigger boobs bigger arms
bigger bank balance faster car
bigger house so on and so forth i
imagine there must be
is there an inversion of a model then
that you
someone that you look to that you're
kind of obsessed with
but is a role model that you're using as
an example of what not to be
everyone's got the the sort of car crash
instagram accounts that they hate watch
all of the stories of online yeah yeah
that we that we hate watch
um you mean me personally or just in
general in terms of the
uh mimetic desire infrastructure i
suppose
i mean i think it's i think it's
critical to have um
those kinds of models that are typically
transcendent to the systems that we're
in um
you know it could be somebody for you
know from from history or just some some
ideal
because if we don't have any kind of
model that transcends
our environment we're kind of constantly
subject to that whatever the tyranny of
our age happens to be
like we're always a product we're always
a child of our age
um and i think that is with the collapse
of
uh with the collapse of of sort of
meaning and grand narratives
we risk we risk that
right we don't have kind of any anything
like
outside of you know it's like you're
you're drowning
in in in quicksand and you don't have
anything to like latch on to
everything that you're grasping for
other people that are also drowning in
in the damn quicksand
so i think it's it's critical to have
some transcendent models it doesn't have
to be a person
um it could be it could be an idea um
right it could be it could be some
something that is kind of what you know
classic or perennial philosophy would
just call like these perennial
truths of what it means to be human and
what leads to it you know to the good
life right as aristotle would say
that uh that can sort of save us from
the the destructive effects of mimesis
to be able to
to have something to hold on to in that
way luke burgess ladies and gentlemen
wanting the power of memetic desire in
everyday life will be linked in the show
notes below
if people want to check out what else
you do where should they go
uh lukeburgest.com uh a lot didn't make
it into the book so i try to write a sub
stack uh called anti-memetic every week
uh where i i try to connect all these
ideas to current events sick man thanks
for coming on
cool thanks so much for having me thank
you very much for tuning in
if you enjoyed that then press here for
a selection of the best clips from the
podcast over the last few months
and don't forget to subscribe makes me
very happy indeed
peace